good morning John it's Monday June 11
good morning Hank
show me that's will over
mr.
Oh
bring out the world
we can take
those are
we got into
what are we doing Hank laying on the
beach in of all places the Dominican
Republic at a family reunion what's the
most exciting part of the family reunion
so far is that the reunion of the
Brotherhood yeah why don't we do like
this every day
where's Catherine she's stuck in Montana
at work which really sucks well it would
suck except that she's doing weed
research well yeah I guess it's nice
that she has a job but it's very sad
that she isn't here even though you have
a Yeti wave hi to Catherine hi we miss
you Catherine visio John I will see you
in a couple of minutes
and the great tradition of brotherhood
2.0 special features here are some
outtakes Monday June 11
we made a lot of money god of masters
are you what happened engine investable
block B the first versions ever heard
drown and physical pain I'm sorry I
thought in fetal position
that's very good Wow